2020 was not a good year to put it
lightly the kovit 19 pandemic reached
practically every corner of the globe
forcing countries to issue lockdowns
millions found themselves unemployed
as businesses close people couldn't even
escape from their troubles at the movie
theaters
as the likes of no time to die black
widow and fast and furious 9 all got
pushed into 2021
match.com seems to understand how
uniquely difficult the year was for
single people
in early december in association with
ryan reynolds production company maximum
effort
the company released a commercial
highlighting the relatable hope
that 2021 will be better than 2020. in
the ad spot
satan strikes up a new romance with a
human personification of 2020
and it's a match made in hell call me
2020
the commercial is enough to give viewers
a serious sense of deja vu
as they watch the couple exercise in an
abandoned gym and hoard toilet paper
but as you watch the match.com ad you
may also start to feel as though you've
seen the woman who plays 2020 before
as it turns out the actress on the
match.com commercial is natalie roy who
has appeared in numerous tv shows and
films in the past roy has been acting
professionally since 2005
when she made her first television
appearance in the canadian drama series
on the run
over the years she has popped up in
various guest spots on a number of tv
series
including blind spots on nbc and the
affair on showtime
in 2018 roy had a prominent role as
claire in the short-lived dark comedy
series after
which follows a widower who attempts to
start dating once again
the show which also stars joshua
schubart and olivia baptista as benny
was nominated for six
indie series awards in 2019 roy isn't
just a talent in front of the cameras
she's also served as a writer director
and or producer on a number of short
films
she released a book in 2013 called 30
years
30 lessons showcasing the stories dreams
and moments that make up a life
as told from the perspective of a 30
year old woman trying to attain her
goals
you can watch a promo she filmed for the
book on her youtube channel
more recently roy appeared opposite
adrian paul
viveka a fox sean young and more in the
thriller film a beautiful distraction
about people who come to realize that
they're living in an alternate timeline
completely different from the one they
once did and just a few days into 2021
roy popped up in an episode of the crime
dramedy series
bull playing a character named olivia
wright in the fifth episode of season
five
it's clear from her extensive resume
that roy is a multifaceted talent
and the match.com 2020 commercial has
introduced her to a massive new audience
after match made in hell dropped two
more ads were released when satan met
2020
and sneak peek at 2021. oh i've dated
much worse guys than him
much worse i mean at least he's famous
the ads have amassed millions of views
and a ton of positive praise with people
really seeming to love the irreverent
take on the last year as well as the
remastered version of the country pop
song love story
by taylor swift that's featured in the
match made in hell spot
in an interview with cbc news roy had
the chance to talk about the process of
bringing the commercial to life stating
i do feel the scripts were so funny and
the physical comedy of the difference in
size between myself
and the gentleman playing the devil was
already so much great material
that i actually feel like i didn't have
to do much work with so much exposure
expect plenty of good things to come for
natalie roy
in the years to come check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one